kyle rittenhouse was found not guilty on
all counts on friday and the left is not
taking it well troy gaston a blm leader
in chicago summed up the response
i want y'all to make some noise for
being survivors man
by having the courage for having the
courage to come back out here when the
system told us that we do not have a
voice because if you come out here
under these situations we will be shut
down
that's what the verdict was all about
it was telling us to be silent
under the threat of complete violence
say hell no
hell no hell no
today
we come out here
simply
to be recognized
as people
who deserve
to live and be treated with equality and
respect
does anybody believe that blm is not
treated with respect
that blm is not recognized
if blm is not treated with equality that
is only because it is given deferential
treatment
blmrs get plea deals and dismissal of
charges for spending six months looting
and burning cities coast to coast
meanwhile horn hat wearing goofballs
rotten solitary confinement for making a
mess of nancy pelosi's office
but in this case in the written house
case the evidence was so weak that even
a unified liberal establishment could
not succeed in sending a teenager to
jail for killing a serial child rapist
in self-defense
so what does blm want now
we wait for the federal government to
charge wooden house with first degree
murder
if you don't win at the state level take
it to the federal if at first you don't
succeed try try again the right is
celebrating a victory for the rule of
law which the persistent left is already
back at work to undermine i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from brian boggs who
says the prosecutors can take comfort in
the fact that we all take a beating
sometimes that's true
that was one of their arguments in the
case and they just got beat and sorry
buddy but you know
we all take a beating some times
one way that we're all very often
getting beat is when big tech comes in
and takes all of our data and spies on
us and and has a lot of information so
how do you protect yourself against that
you check out
expressvpn chances are the browser
you're using right now has made its
fortune by tracking your movements
online
so i have a feeling if you're listening
to this shows maybe sometimes you use
that at incognito window you know you
you want to hide something you're
looking at some dubious websites like
dailywire.com you know what i'm talking
about well incognito does not mean
invisible all right how do you actually
make yourself as invisible as possible
online you use expressvpn like i do
you've got to make sure that your online
activity is not getting tracked
these data brokers are going out and
buying and selling your data one of the
data points is your ip address data
harvesters use your ip to uniquely
identify you and your location but with
expressvpn your connection gets rerouted
through an encrypted server and your ip
address is masked best of all expressvpn
is super duper easy to use one button
use it on your phone on your on your
tablet on your laptop if you really want
to go incognito for real protect your
privacy with the number one rated vpn in
america go to expressvpn.com michael get
three extra months for free exp
essvpn.com
michael expressvpn
michael to learn more
breaking news right now breaking news
this morning out of waukesha wisconsin
there was a parade in waukesha and
someone drove an suv speeding down the
parade trying to kill as many people as
possible by all appearances five people
are dead 40 people are injured
there is footage we're not going to play
it it's very difficult to watch and i
don't think there's any reason to play
it andy no right now who has done a
great job exposing militant leftist
groups antifa and blm andy knows
reporting that the suspect who is
arrested
is a blm supporter he's a young black
male he's apparent his social media is
apparently riddled with uh pro blm
george floyd riot types of posts
uh he he reportedly again not just from
andy now but other outlets are reporting
that he was out on a one thousand dollar
bail
earlier this week for an earlier crime
and so because of the compassionate
policy of letting criminals off the hook
now five people are dead at least and 40
people
are injured
we don't know for certain that he was a
blm supporter but the attack did take
place an hour outside of kenosha
the
it would appear at least that there is
some connection there but the cops are
quiet about this so we don't we don't
have any confirmed information
yet
very difficult to believe that this was
an accident doesn't look like an
accident
at all
more
more from the mostly peaceful crowd
meanwhile cnn
cnn we'll we're going to hold off
reporting more on that until until more
information is available meanwhile cnn
has this headline there's nothing more
frightening in america today
than an angry white man
there it is there it is you you awful
white man i'm sure some of you in the
audience at least are white men some of
you are probably pretty angry hearing
that headline well you're the most
dangerous person in america according to
john blake some race hustler at cnn now
there are a lot of problems with this
headline
the first one is it's just not true
okay it's offensive it's racist it's
mean spirit it's it's divisive sure it's
also just not true here we have a report
from the u.s department of justice
office of justice programs bureau of
justice statistics this is from january
2021.
here is race and ethnicity of violent
crime offenders and arrestees 2018 here
is the first sentence of the first
paragraph in 2018 based on data from the
fbi's uniform crime reporting program
black people were over-represented among
persons arrested for non-fatal violent
crimes and for serious non-fatal violent
crimes relative to their representation
in the u.s population
white people were underrepresented white
people accounted for 60 of us residents
but 46 percent of all persons arrested
for rape robbery aggravated assault and
other assault and 39 of all arrestees
for non-fatal violent crimes excluding
other assault hispanics regardless of
their race were overrepresented among
arrestees for non-fatal violent crimes
excluding other assault relative their
to their population or representation in
the u.s population so
and not angry white men angry white men
basically the least likely to
attack you now what the left will say is
well michael those statistics by
definition are only
representing people who are arrested for
these crimes
so it might be the case that white
people are committing a gazillion
murders they're just not getting
arrested for it in order to believe that
you need to believe
that there is some conspiracy either of
black victims
or white victims or hispanics or any
kind of victims who are all colluding
together
not to report certain crimes
to the police
because they don't want
white men to get in trouble
in order to believe that you have to
believe that for instance the new york
police department which is majority
minority right it's not not majority
white
uh is colluding just to
make make sure that white people don't
show up in the crime statistics but of
course that's not the case okay so the
first part of the headline that's that's
false is
the headline right i mean
rather the first the first part that's
wrong about the headline is just that it
isn't
true
here's a quote from it this angry white
man has been a major character
throughout u.s history he gave the
country slavery the slaughter of native
americans and jim crow laws
again that's not true the white man
didn't
give the country slavery he didn't
create slavery slavery was practiced in
africa long before the white man ever
got there and was practiced long after
the white man left
or after the transatlantic slave trade
not just africa slavery is practiced
everywhere in the world outside of the
west the unique thing about the west is
not that we created slavery it's that we
abolished slavery that's that's what's
unique about the west the slaughter of
native americans native americans were
slaughtering one another long before the
white man ever got here okay and the
slaughter continued after the white man
arrived
just a few years before columbus's
arrival in the americas the aztecs
slaughtered 80 000 people in four days
at the consecration of tenochtitlan
that's just one
native american nation
just one among many many many
and jim crow laws okay i guess the white
man did that
one out of three one out of three
now
what's more interesting about this
headline to me than just the race
hustling which is so typical of cnn and
yes it's obviously ridiculous but
whatever what's more interesting
than that to me
is
the victim mentality you saw that
actually in the video from from kenosha
where that other race hustler had
justice for victims or i'm sorry the
video was from chicago but it was about
what was going on in kenosha it said
justice for victims
although right now there is a revolt
against western civilization and really
what you call christendom right
christianity
the concern for victims
is
exclusively a creation of judaism and
christianity
the concern for victims taking the side
of victims does not exist
in non-jewish and non-christian cultures
okay you see it uniquely in the bible
and then it finds its fullest expression
in christianity through the passion of
christ where not only are we taking not
only does god take the sight of the
victims but god actually is the victim
here and takes the side of the victims
right this is an idea
that that was expounded upon by a
sociologist by the name of renee gerard
who died only recently he was at
stanford and he he has this idea
the at the heart of of culture
is rivalry memetic rivalry that we that
we kind of imitate one another and
because of this we end up killing one
another we end up in a state of war of
all against all this is why all the
stories about the creation of
civilization tend to involve brothers
right romulus and remus kane and abel
these two mirrors of one another that
that become more and more uh rivalistic
and then eventually this leads to a
murder
and
in when you take it beyond just one
person against one person you see it in
scapegoating the idea that the only way
for the the culture the society to
resolve all of this tension is to
scapegoat someone literally the
scapegoat would be to put all of the
evils and all of the sins onto a goat
and then send the goat out into the
wilderness
or to just attack one group of people or
to attack one person and the trick about
scapegoating is
you never know when you're the one doing
it when you're scapegoating you always
think that you're completely justified
and you're on the we all do this
you never are aware of that and what the
left isn't aware of right now is that
they are scapegoating in the law in the
media in the culture they are
scapegoating the straight white male is
the cause of all the evils in the world
according to them and they think they
think preposterously that they're on the
side of justice
when all this political craziness it
really makes you want to
have some tangible assets which is why i
would recommend you check out acre gold
inflation is going through the roof
a great way to hedge against inflation
is physical gold an acre will let you
subscribe to physical gold bars for as
little as 30 bucks a month now what
you're thinking is
i thought i thought physical gold cost
more than 30 bucks yeah it does
but acre has this ingenious way of
investing where you subscribe to the
gold bars you send in 30 bucks a month
when your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars they will discreetly
ship acre gold to your house they also
have a 100 a month subscription to a
five gram gold bar if you want to up the
ante a little i've always enjoyed
investing in physical precious metals
okay i've enjoyed investing in acre gold
go check it out go to
getacregold.com knowles know w-l-e-s
start investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to that url because
acre is giving away a gold bar to
qualify for the giveaway tweet or post
why you should be the recipient and
mention at get underscore acre that is
get acre gold dot com slash knowles
canada w l e s thank you acre gold for
supporting the show
nicole hannah jones
she is the fabulous behind the 16 19
project at the new york times she's the
one who who pushed this now mainstream
thesis that america was founded to
defend slavery it's completely
without evidence actually the new york
times had to admit that the central
thesis was bs but it doesn't matter they
keep promoting it anyway and now it's
made its way into schools
so for nicole hannah jones everything
every single thing must be the fault of
white people and white supremacy so
after the written house verdict she
tweeted out quote in this country
you can even kill white people and get
away with it if those white people are
fighting for black lives this is the
legacy of 1619.
nicole hannah jones knows that she can't
say
that kyle rittenhouse
killed black people because
he didn't kill any black people and the
media tried to present it as though that
were the case but the only people that
kyle written has shot were white people
so so
nicole hannah jones
in order to make her theory fit
she needs to make those white people
that written house killed into black
people
or into avatars of black people
now all the white people that written
house killed were trying to kill written
house
beyond that one of the people written
house killed
was a serial child rapist
another guy that written has killed beat
women in his own family i think he beat
his own mother i mean these are people
who are so cartoonishly evil
that if you turned it into a hollywood
producer and you said hey here's the the
kenosha story and this kid is going to
kill
you know a child rapist and a mother
beater and all these the the producer
would look at you and say that's a
little too on the nose buddy come on
that's a little ridiculous there's no
way but
what is astounding to me is not that in
this country you can you can even kill
white people and get away with it if
they're fighting for black lives the
legacy of 1619. what's astounding to me
is that in this country
journalists will lament the death of a
serial child rapist
who was shot while trying to kill a 17
year old
because that's the legacy of the 1960s
right that's the legacy and what what it
comes out of it gets back to this idea
of the the victim mechanism
the left
wants to take the side of the victim i
want to be as charitable as i can to the
left they think they're taking the side
of the victim they think the victim is
black people and brown people and women
and
people who have different sexual desires
and the marginalized and the oppressed
and whatever right so that's they're
taking the side of the victim against
the evil white man who's the cause of
all the evil in the world
christianity right the prevailing
society
and christianity too is taking the side
of the victims
any concern for victims that anyone has
ever had in the world comes out of
christianity comes out of christian
culture and so now you've got these two
rivals and actually this sociologist
renee gerard makes the point that woke
ism he doesn't call it this because it
was a little too early but what he's
referring to is wokism or political
correctness
is a kind of mirror of christianity
and now they too are locked in a kind of
rivalry and and the
the
the problem of this of course is you can
never see
that you are the one
scapegoating people so so
nicole hannah jones who is a very
prominent person she's maybe not a very
intelligent person or a very serious but
she's very prominent
she can actually twist herself into a
logical pretzel to say that a white kid
shooting a couple of white criminals who
were trying to shoot him or trying to
kill him more broadly one was trying to
shoot him
that somehow that is
an example
of white supremacy
this is
critical race theory we talk about
critical race theory and it's it seems
like this very nebulous concept what
everything is critical race theory or
the left is nothing is critical race
theory so winsome sears
who
who just became the lieutenant governor
of virginia
she was running along with glenn juncken
winsome sears
a black woman herself just went on cnn
and
and encountered the line that we're all
encountering about critical race theory
this is the official party line of cnn
namely
critical race theory is not being taught
in schools and she says that's bunk
you oppose critical race theory being
taught in schools which i should say is
not part of virginia's curriculum
you did say though that the good and the
bad of american history should be taught
and
uh that we should also tell viewers
you're the former vice president of the
virginia board of education so explain
how you think race should be taught
in virginia public schools well let me
back up
i beg to differ that crt is not taught i
didn't say that i just said it's not in
the curriculum just to be clear
no no no no it is part of the curriculum
it's weaved in and out of the curriculum
in fact in 2015 former governor uh who
was just defeated mcauliffe his state
board of education had information on
how to teach it so it's weaved in so you
know it's semantics but it's weaved in
so love this she won't let cnn get away
with this cnn says beep boop
beep beep boop no critical race theory
in schools in virginia schools
i'm a talking head on cnn and then
the person they're talking to is the
former vice president of the virginia
school board so she says actually
uh cnn lady you have no idea what you're
talking about and i worked in this very
closely and
absolutely critical race theory is being
taught in virginia schools and we just
won an election because of that
and then the cnn lady is smart enough to
know that she's not going to be able to
win the point she's not going to be able
to refute that fact with winsome sears
so she says well no no i
i didn't say it's not being taught
i said
it's not in the curriculum
which is
a distinction without a difference
even the point
the
side point she's trying to make even the
retreating point she's trying to make is
not true
the curriculum is
the schedule of things that are taught
if something is taught
it is in the curriculum
well no it's just some one random
teacher saying something that's what the
left might they say no it's just some
teacher going off script no it's not
it's being taught as a part of the
program
it is in the curriculum which is what
winsome sears is saying and
what the way the left tries to get away
with this line is they say well there's
no unit of critical race theory it's not
as though students are taught okay now
we're going to learn about the american
revolution and now we're going to learn
about you know the enlightenment and now
we're going to learn about critical race
theory and now we're going to learn
about calculus right it's not
that's not how it's taught but that's
not what critical race theory is
critical race theory isn't
a specific
academic
uh
it is a movement it's not a specific
academic field or or a
unit
it is a an analytical framework
so it's it's not taught as just one
thing
critical race theory is a lens through
which you view all the other things
so no you're not going to spend two
weeks learning critical race theory
you're going to spend
a whole school year learning critical
race theory as it pertains to history as
it pertains to literature as it pertains
to economics as it pertains to
everything and that's what winsome sears
has to say
it's much worse don't let them tell you
that there's no lesson on critical race
theory in schools it's much worse than
that it's in all of the lessons
critical race theory says that
everything about america is hopelessly
rotten because
it is all
formed by white supremacy
and so everything about america the
culture the tastes the history the
military movements the the form of
government the form of economics it's
all
hopelessly irredeemably
rotten because of white supremacy and
it's all going to be ripped out
by the root
and
beyond that what if if you can get the
left to admit that critical race theory
does play some role in the education as
that cnn lady started to have to admit
the next thing they'll tell you is
that you as a parent have no right to
stop it
this was another
another this was a really great weekend
for dumb columns on
legacy media outlets there was a piece
that went up on nbc this is by christina
wyman who is the author of some some new
novel and she's
i guess an educator she's a former at
least a former middle school teacher
and she's she has very strong views on
on the role that parents should have in
their kids education she really thinks
that parents should have no role
and so she published on nbc
what i think
it i don't want to be hyperbolic here it
it might be the dumbest thing i've ever
read
and and i read a lot of really really
dumb things this might be
this might take the cake
the headline is schools face parents who
want to ban critical race theory and
don't get how teaching works
so it's not that they don't get what
critical race theory is it's not that
they don't get how the how the schools
are ordering their curricula it's that
they don't get what teaching is
subheader an educator's top goal is to
teach students to think parents who
dictate curricula with their personal
opinions ideologies and biases hinder
that goal
forget about teachers who who
imbue the curricula with their opinions
ideologies and biases that
it's the parents who have any say over
what is taught
they are a threat
to education
got to watch out how these people use
language like for instance a lot of
times at the grocery store
ranchers will use this language you know
made in america or usa meat and it won't
really be that it'll actually be meat
that's imported from
say latin american then they just slap a
usa label on it don't get tricked check
out the good ranchers since 2015 over
100 000 independent farms and ranches in
the us have shut down why because
foreign meat is stealing their business
and robbing you of the quality and
flavor that you deserve that is why good
ranchers is here they exist to support
local american farms and help you make
great american meals together they want
to restore the american ranch and your
meals to their former glory get the beef
chicken and seafood that can't be
imported or matched at goodranchers.com
good ranchers is here to put america
first at the dinner table and the
farmers that worked to raise the meat we
eat really really great stuff i
especially love their burgers
all their stuff is terrific but me
they're burgers they're so juicy they're
so american i just love them go to
goodranchers.com
knowles canada les right now get 10 free
bistro fillets
and in addition if you subscribe you
will save 25 off of each subscription
box of mouth-watering american meats for
life these boxes will show up on
schedule right to your door so you get
10 free bistro fillets that's a 100
value free express shipping and 25 off
your monthly subscription for live at
goodranchers.com knowles that's
goodrangers.com use codenoles at
checkout 10 free bistro filets 25 bucks
off your monthly subscription for life
goodranchers.com knowles also if you've
been worrying about what you're going to
get your loved ones this christmas i've
got excellent news for you the daily
wire merch store is here it is ready to
be explored
head on over to dailywire.com
shop to check out the collection of
let's go brand and tailgate gear and so
much more anyone can shop at the daily
wire store but only daily wire members
will get special discounts up to 20 off
members also receive access to shop
exclusive merch like the daily wire
leftist tears
tumbler people have wanted to buy the
tumbler stand alone for a very long time
that opportunity is now here head on
over to dailywire.com shop
if you're not a member yet sign up right
now go to dailywire.com subscribe enter
code dw35
to get 35
off your membership we'll be right back
with a lot more
nbc a writer for nbc and a former
teacher
says that you as a parent have
absolutely no right
to have a say in your kids education she
writes quote parents have always tried
to interfere with curricula as i
observed when teaching middle school in
the mid-2000s
even then there was no shortage of
parental input about the content of my
instruction from books to test questions
part of the problem is that parents
think that they have the right to
control teaching and learning because
their children are the ones being
educated but it actually gasp she writes
gasp in parentheses doesn't work that
way it's sort of like entering a
surgical unit thinking you can interfere
with an operation simply because the
patient is your child
so i'm going to pause it right there
a lot of conservatives are saying this
is an imp precise analogy and it's crazy
to compare educating to surgery for
instance
i actually think the the analogy is okay
i think it's a pretty good analogy
but the fact is parents do have a say in
their kids medical decisions
they do i know that the left doesn't
think they do anymore the left is saying
we're going to jab your kid with the
fouchyauchi regardless of what you want
we're going to trans your kid we're
going to take your little boy and chop
him up and make him look like a little
girl regardless of what you want because
we know what's best but actually believe
it or not parents do have a say
in
surgery
and
by the way education is as formal at
least as formative as surgeries are you
are shaping the way that a child will
view the world you are shaping what a
child thinks about what is true and
false and right and wrong and good and
bad when you educate them
certainly when you educate them for 13
years or more
so yeah it is
it is a lot like surgery
and the parents have a right over how
their child is formed and these really
really important
decisions that will shape their entire
life the woman goes on she says teaching
too is a science unless they're licensed
and certified parents aren't qualified
to make decisions about curricula in
fact parental interference can actually
hinder student advancement an educator's
primary goal is to teach students to
think
parents who attempt to influence
curricula with their personal opinions
ideologies and biases hinder that goal
an educator's goal is to teach students
to think
what does that mean
what exactly does that mean it's it's i
think it's a similar version to we teach
students how to think not what to think
but of course the educators are teaching
students what to think
here's here's something
an educator's primary goal is to teach
students to think
that is a what that's not a how that's a
what
that's ideology
that's personal opinion that's bias
that's
the same thing that the educator is
accusing the parents of doing
kind of gets back to our point about
scapegoating
for for these teachers for the left
broadly
parents are the pro they are the problem
because the parents are trying to teach
students
something about
the world they're trying to form the way
their students and children view the
world
of course the same could be said of the
the educators that that's what they're
doing
but they can't the the left the
educators can't see that what they
believe that what they're doing is
totally just and right and the other
people are completely totally
wrong
if an educator like this kooky woman
teaches a student that a boy can become
a girl
then that educator is hindering the
student's education because that
educator is teaching the student
something that isn't true if the
educator says that america was founded
in 1619 and the central fact of america
is slavery
that educator is hindering the student's
education because the educator is
teaching the students something that
isn't true
and if a parent comes in and says get
that crap out of the classroom
the parent is helping the student's
education
because the parent is
kicking away the things that are false
and and demanding that students be
taught things that are true
and this is now a battle
for
the minds
and souls
of the next generation of americans
and who's going to be better at that
left-wing ideologue teachers
or
parents
the democratic party sent out a tweet
just today
said
that the number one occupation for
democrat donors
in recent years
is teachers
exactly
exactly that's the problem
so if you want your kids
to be taught the
democrat leftist liberal view of the
world an evil view of the world that is
not true and it's not good and it's not
beautiful
then we have to well let's let things be
the way they are let's back off let's
never question any of the teachers let's
not show up to school boards if you
don't want your kids to turn out that
way
then we need to politically get a little
bit aggressive and we need to show up to
school boards and we need to demand
resignations and we need to demand that
lunatic teachers like this woman
christina wyman get fired that they
don't have a platform that we cancel
them we need to cancel this we need to
cancel the bad books in the education we
need to cancel the stupid ideas in the
education and we need to cancel the bad
teachers and administrators and they
need to be fired and they never should
be allowed in your students ever again
okay and are conservatives willing to
say that are conservatives willing to do
that
i think so i think you're beginning to
see a movement on the right that's
that's doing that ron desantis in
florida is doing that a lot of
candidates for senate right now blake
masters whom i just sat down with he's
he's saying these sorts of things jd
vance josh mandel in ohio both running
against one another they're saying these
sorts of things that's what we got to do
got to get
much tougher there's a shocking report
out of a school in california
abigail schreier
who wrote irreversible damage it's a
book about how the culture is transiting
little girls and then they're regretting
it and then you're that's not being
reported on
there was a book that was i think was
cancelled from target
then there was an uproar it went back to
target it's a very good book
abigail schreier
revealed that at a late october meeting
at a conference of california's largest
teachers union the california teachers
association cta
documents show that teachers were
encouraged to recruit students into lgbt
clubs
to urge them to quote have the courage
to create a safe environment that
fosters bravery to explore sexual
orientation
and
quote this is what one of the teachers
reportedly said quote we're going to do
just a little mind trick on our sixth
graders so recruiting 11 year olds to
explore their sexual orientation
in clubs that by the way
don't keep records so this was another
aspect of it
laurie caldera who's who's a middle
school teacher buena vista middle school
teacher in california an lgbtq club
leader was heard on tape saying quote
because we're not official we have no
club rosters we keep no records in fact
sometimes we don't really want to keep
records because if parents get upset
that their kids are coming we're like
yeah i don't know maybe they came you
know we would never want a kid to get in
trouble for attending if their parents
are upset so these are teachers who are
recruiting kids into these clubs not
keeping records of it stonewalling the
parents if the parents have any
questions and transiting the freaking
kids
you know i don't i don't want to sound
hyperbolic about it
i don't you know i don't want to put on
my alex jones voice even though alex
jones has been right about a number of
things like the gay frogs
but
but
we have record of this
audio record documents being reported by
a very serious respected source abigail
schreier
that these teachers are trying to trans
the kids it's exactly what conservatives
have been talking about
schreier even went on she said
speakers went so far as to tout their
surveillance of students google searches
internet activity and hallway
conversations in order to target sixth
graders for personal invitations to
lgbtq clubs
while actively concealing the club's
membership roles from participants
parents
so this question
beyond the specific sexual questions
raised the extreme creepiness of this
the the i assume illegality of some of
this i assume that the schools need to
keep better records and are not allowed
to stonewall parents this way but beyond
all of that
it actually comes down to a very simple
mundane question
who has to the right to raise your kids
for the last 20 or 30 years
and i guess really even a little before
that
the right would say
just us just the parents it's just us
and what the left has said is it takes a
village right so meaning that was
hillary clinton's memoir title so
hillary clinton
representing the left's view here would
say actually parents have very few
rights and it's all
the society
really they mean the government
and the right would say forget society
forget the government it's all parents
and
the real answer is it's it's both it is
both
there's a reason that it takes a village
to raise a child is an old idiom is that
it's true
and i'm not even saying this
prescriptively i'm not even saying it
should be the case that it takes a
village to raise a child i'm just saying
it does
your kids are going are going to be
influenced by the village that is
inevitable
you can be the most protective
helicopter parent you ever saw
and your kids are still going to be
influenced by the neighbors
by the other kids that they meet in the
neighborhood or at school if they're
going to a school they're going to be
influenced by what they see on tv
they're going to be influenced by
things they see on billboards that you
can't lock them up in a little room
forever they are going to be influenced
by
society and this is why it's not enough
to just take the udu laissez-faire
hands-off approach to politics that a
lot of conservatives
demonstrating i think a lot of cowardice
in recent decades have done they've said
no forget it whatever you want to do is
find as long as it doesn't affect me
well it does affect you
even the private stuff even the personal
stuff it does affect you because we live
in society
that's politics means the public stuff
right that's all public and political
mean the same thing
and so it is going to affect you
and to some degree your kid is going to
be raised by the village and to some
degree the kid is going to be raised by
you and it is up to us asserting our
political rights to decide exactly what
that balance is
if these lunatics at nbc and in the
california teachers unions and
in the democratic party have their way
the parents are going to have no rights
whatsoever and the village that raises
the kids is going to be a radical
leftist village that fills your kids
heads with insane racial and sexual
views
you can't we can't let them do that
and we need to recognize that because
the village does have a say we need to
assert our political rights not just you
know politics is downstream of culture
i'm just going to work on myself and
look at the man in the mirror you got to
do that too but you got to show up to
that school board you got to show up to
the elections you got to fire these bad
teachers you got to kick the pornography
out of schools you got to kick the 1619
project out of schools but i repeat
myself frankly so not not quite obscene
in the same way that pornography is but
it is obscenely anti-historical it is
obscenely anti-american it's obscenely
false
you've got to assert your political
power
speaking of political rights there is a
cop who got fired for donating to kyle
rittenhouse lieutenant william kelly
from the norfolk police department
was fired
because he made a 25 anonymous donation
to kyle rittenhouse's legal defense
was gonna do it on gofundme gofundme
barred donations to kyle rittenhouse's
legal defense because gofundme is a
far-left organization that targets
conservatives
so then there was another one who's give
send go was the more conservative
version of it
this cop gives 25 bucks to this kid's
legal defense
hackers
obtained kelly's name and address email
address
gave it to the guardian a left-wing
paper the guardian ran a story
kelly got fired because the police chief
larry boone
suggested that he lose his job larry
boone the police chief the norfolk
police chief was a supporter of blm
he attended a blm protest fully
uniformed last may
and he said no this this cop gave 25
bucks to kyle rittenhouse he's got to be
fired and the city manager accepted that
recommendation
kyle rittenhouse was was vindicated
cal rittenhouse did nothing wrong the
court of law determined that he acted in
self-defense
he this man should never have been fired
frankly i think the police chief
probably should have been fired for
showing up to the blm protest
his blm is a terrorist organization
what i would do if i were a constituent
if i lived in norfolk virginia what i
would do
i'd probably call up that norfolk
virginia police department
i would probably ask to speak to police
chief larry boone
and i would probably demand that he be
reinstated and furthermore if i were a
constituent in norfolk virginia i would
probably demand that the police chief
here larry boone lose his job
i i what i would demand is the opposite
of what actually happened
because the media narrative we were told
is that kyle rittenhouse was a terrorist
domestic violent white supremacist
whatever stupid slogan you want to hear
and he killed peaceful protesters and
that isn't true it turned out the
opposite was true
and so instead of
lieutenant william kelly losing his job
and larry boone getting to laugh about
it i think probably the opposite should
be true i think police chief larry boone
should lose his job i think people ought
to probably call that police department
and demand the reinstatement
of lieutenant william kelly that's just
what i would do if i were a constituent
of norfolk virginia though though i
unlike my colleague matt walsh i'm not a
trans virginian
the kyle rittenhouse case
was so clear
after we saw the evidence after the
media narrative went away it was so
clear
that even
people on cnn
are beginning to admit it during the
tweedledee tweedledum handoff between
chris cuomo and don lemon
these two fellas
even managed to admit
that the verdict was right
you know you know you're gonna have
people saying if he was black this would
be different right because we're dealing
with systemic injustice right now and
even though this verdict i believe is
justified by the law and the facts here
that's what we should want every time
people are frustrated that you wouldn't
get it if he was black even though this
may be the right outcome
but
at the same time you're doing that
you're going to have him be weaponized
by one of the most toxic people and
outfits in our society
well so there are therefore when um that
judge said this when he you know dressed
down the prosecutor's prosecution did a
lot of things wrong right i mean this
really rests but they had a a hard case
they had a hard case but they didn't do
a good job even with a hard case i mean
that's obvious to see
so it's mostly chris cuomo who's
admitting that the verdict was right and
don lemon's trying not to but lemon is
smart enough to realize that he can't
make a good argument here so he says
well
you know it was just that prosecution ah
that prosecution
and chris cuomo says what about the
prosecution
they had a hard case
really they had an impossible case
the best shot they had was to
to keep evidence from the defense and to
they called their best witnesses all
those witnesses ended up making the case
for the defense not the prosecution
you could have had the greatest lawyers
in the world
all right the two prosecutors
in kenosha
blinken and is that his name blinken or
i don't even remember his name anymore
or the one they called lunchbox those
two guys talk about tweedledee
tweedledum they did not do a good job
they are not very good lawyers
but
you could have had
alan dershowitz and johnny cochran and
ken starr and all the greatest lawyers
in the country and they still couldn't
have made the case because the evidence
wasn't there that's the point chris
cuomo was making now why
why are these gentlemen on cnn making
this point right now
is it because they have integrity
maybe
i don't want to say certainly that they
don't have integrity
cuomo and lemon both in earlier eras
have been more balanced than they are
now they're probably just getting a call
from the head of cnn saying you got to
be more leftist and and combative i
didn't chris cuomo he got caught on that
audio just some months ago saying he
hates his job and he feels like a hack
and all this so
maybe it's that
i suspect
the reason that they're coming out now
and saying oh the verdict was probably
right and hey you know look whatever
it's okay it's all good
it's because they know
that their network spent a lot of time
spreading a lot of lies
and slander
and liable
about kyle rittenhouse
it's not just cnn it's nbc and the
washington post the new york times and
all of them and i think they remember
nick sandman you remember nick sandman
he was that kid wearing the maga hat
when the native american lunatic started
banging a drum in his face and the black
supremacists were screaming slurs at
them
and he smiled and after smiling all the
media outlets called him a white
supremacist and all that i
do you remember what happened after that
oh yeah nick sandman shook them all down
for a ton of money
we don't know the exact number because
there were non-disclosures there but
nick salmon made a lot of money off
those guys
and i think cnn is trying to cover its
derriere
and i hope oh do i hope
that now that kyle rittenhouse has been
exonerated
i hope he takes them to the cleaners i
hope
that kyle rittenhouse
becomes a trillionaire
suing these dirtbag liberal journal
outlets into the dirt
i hope that
kyle rittenhouse and nick sandman
have to split
time
owning these various outlets like
divorced parents i hope it's like okay
kyle you can have cnn on the weekends
but i nick i want to have cnn during the
week and then maybe for the summers i
want it to be
unambiguous
i want these guys to lose a lot of money
justice was served in the case we've
talked so much about the kyle written
house case i guess that's now coming to
an end we're going to move on to the
next
left-wing hoax
but
just because justice was served that's
great
we've got to keep it up okay
just like you heard that the blm guy
he said no well yeah okay he was
exonerated at the state level
we want federal charges
right the left never gives up
the left is really persistent we've got
to be persistent too we won we've got to
take it further
gotta sue those media outlets into
oblivion
what the left is trying to do in this
country is delegitimize the opposition
this is a story this actually came out a
couple weeks ago
but it i think it pertains to what's
going on now mike cernovich discovered
this
the washington post was running an ad
to promote the idea of january 6 the
insurrection they were running in
advertisements at an investigation by
the washington post provides the richest
understanding to date of trump's mindset
and the cost of his inaction as
democracy came under attack
now i'm not saying
that it's weird for a journalistic
outlet to run ads on their stories
but you know everyone does that we do
that everybody does it
but
it is weird to run ads on a story that
doesn't really catch
right no one really believes the january
6th thing the whole narrative is falling
apart we were told january 6 was a bunch
of domestic terrorists who came in armed
who killed a cop who were taking over
the government and then the more we've
learned about it the less and less it
see it seems true actually almost every
single thing we were told about that day
was a lie
so the story has kind of fallen apart
in a normal world that would be the end
of the story and they'd move on to
something else but the left is so
dead set on keeping this narrative
that they've got to promote it just like
the new york times story on on the 6019
project the thesis of that was proven
incorrect the new york times spent
millions of dollars promoting it anyway
because they have ideological goals as
well and the goal here is to not merely
win a political battle it's to utterly
delegitimize the opposition
such that any time they get any power or
win at all it is considered a threat to
my an existential threat to democracy to
the country to the republic to the
constitution and it must be
done away with
those are the stakes here
what kind of persistence is the right
willing to engage what kind of law fair
what kind of electioneering what kind of
protest
what kind of legislating is there is the
right willing to do
the left the left is playing for keeps
are we willing to play for keeps too i
hope so i'm michael knowles this is the
michael she'll see tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021 on
the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show
you